human behavior is very complex it has
all kinds of things we're certainly not
going to economics is certainly not
about passion there's a famous line from
the great economist alfred marshall 19th
century congress that economics is about
the ordinary business of life so it's
not about the grand passions it's about
you know deciding what kind of sandwich
you're going to order it's about
deciding where to open a business it's
it can take on anything that that is in
with that within that range
mostly economics is about things where
people are relatively rational it
doesn't have to be because not
everything in the economic field is
rational but it's a set of methods and
it's no I'm not a there in the academic
world we talk about you know academic
imperialists there are economists who
want think that you can use economic
analysis to explain everything and I'm
not one of them
you certainly have to try I mean if it's
again there are some people who think
well if you can't quite model it using
it you know using supply and demand and
then it you have to pretend it doesn't
exist if you're one of the big themes of
my book of conscience of liberal is that
things like norms institutions make a
very big difference so even if you don't
have a extremely rigorous way of
representing them it's actually clear
that they make an enormous difference
you change the changes in American
society and what we expect what we
consider appropriate and let's say the
way corporate management is paid have
been as important as any of the standard
forces of supply and demand
if you say something is true in practice
but not in theory that really means is
there's something wrong with your fury
right if it's your theory we ought to be
able to encompass that now what is true
you have simple models and sometimes
they're wrong so you know there's so
many places where econ 101 doesn't work
there are many places where it does econ
101 tells you that that if you put a
price control on on rental units you're
going to have a housing shortage and
that's right
but econ 101 might suggest to you that
if you deregulate electricity in
California it's it's going to be just
fine but if you go a little bit beyond
economics 101 you can see that you
actually have created an incentive for
producers to game the market and you're
going to get something like the crisis
that actually happened